I want to invite you into effervescence
I want to invite you into iridescent I
want to invite you into sunkissed
ecstasy I want to invite you into the
Golden Hour
venire I believe the function of art is
to serve as a portal as an invitation
into an altered state an extraordinary
moment of poetry and grace what
interests me is the author Inge of
transitory enchanted moments that take
our breath away what I want for you is
to be compelled into aesthetic
contemplations face-to-face beholding
something fast and finally could measure
it to your capacity for wonder but I
want for you is an experience a series
of experiences that blast new tunnels
between the mind and the other I want to
pierce your representations I want you
to remember that the map is not the
territory I want to hurl you into
domains off the reservation I want to
invite you into mythopoetic spaces I
want to hurl you into the domains of
spirits the liminal spaces the threshold
spaces the intermediate spaces between
one world and another
it is said that human beings live in two
domains the transactional and the
transcendent the transactional is the
instrumental it is the goods and
services exchanged it is the oaken tile
economy it is the grid that keeps order
in the world right it is Chronos it is
mechanized cognition
that's the transaction but the
transcendent is the domain of the
non-transactional the domain of the
timeless the domain when you unplug from
the day-to-day right it's Nicci's those
that were seeing dancing were called
answered by those who could not hear the
music I want to be for you a doorway
into the mythopoetic realms I want to be
for you a doorway into the dance whereas
my friend Jason could been told me one
time into Lou at the still point there
the dance is
what's that quote I went to God just to
see I was looking at me Carl Sagan say
we are a way for the cosmos to know
itself
he also said understanding is a kind of
ecstasy and he also said somewhere
something incredible is waiting to be
known
[Music]
positive psychologists tell us that
experiences of experiences of such
perceptual vastness that our mental
models of the world that our Maps are
obliterated in quaint annihilating glory
provide for a finally a glimpse of that
which is beyond our maps and that state
of forced accommodation that encounter
with the mysterium tremendum not only is
it healing not only does it replenish
not only does it renew and reboot but
thereafter it leaves an afterglow of
increased well-being increased
compassion increased creativity it
increased empathy Timothy Leary was
right in order to use your head you've
got to go out of your mind so there you
go my friends my videos these
transmissions these dances of light
these digitized celluloid musings these
artful articulations these ecstatic
vocalizations the words that leap to
mind without having to be called for the
capacity to exercise agency to steer
internal life to some incoherence in the
Pardo's between one statement and other
this dance is
for you it's for me it's for our common
ecstasy
[Music]
so I thank you and I love you and I gift
you iridescent and effervescence poetry
grace love aw wonder rapture radiance
and bliss for you it's all for me and
this is our calm and ecstasy it's all
for you it's all for me and this is our
calm and ecstasy it's all for you it's
all for me and this is our common
ecstasy it's all for you all for me and
this is our common ecstasy
[Music]
you